zdf heute live herzlich willkommen der
krimi um die nummer eins der tennis
weltrangliste geht weiter jetzt hat der
australische einwanderungsminister alex
hock das visum für den ungeimpften
tennisprofi novak djokovic erneut für
ungültig erklärt und das ist seine
begründung
heute habe ich von meiner befugnis
gebrauch gemacht und das visum von herrn
novak djokovic aus gründen der
gesundheit und der guten ordnung
aufgehoben da dies im öffentlichen
interesse liegt die regierung ist fest
entschlossen die grenzen australiens zu
schützen insbesondere im zusammenhang
mit der komik 19 pandemie
tja dass er an den australian open
teilnehmen wird wird damit immer
unwahrscheinlicher darüber reden wir mit
ihnen und euch die kommentare wie immer
in die kommentare oder an die
eingeblendete e mail adresse bitte und
wir reden darüber mit sven arme gern der
gerade noch ein paar fliegen im
australischen melbourne verscheuchen
musste aber inhaltlich natürlich voll
auf ballhöhe unterwegs ist was ist da
jetzt los
ja die fliegen um das ganz kurz zu
lernen sind
eine wirkliche pracht hier und eine
plage die kommen eigentlich anmeldung
gar nicht vor noch mal findet man die
mehr in western australia oder in einen
stränden aber die haben jetzt mehr über
uns innenstadt entdeckt warum auch immer
und freunde mich wie ihr hier sehen
könnt also bitte nicht wundern wenn ich
ab und zu mal meinen kopf bewegen das
liegt daran dass die fliegen doch zu
nervig sind aber kommen wir zur novak
djokovic
kurz vor 6 kam hier schlug hier die
bombe ein alex rock hat sich dann bereit
erklärt dann das visum zu canceln ihr
habt die gründe gerade vorgelesen das
ist genauso gewesen eine neuigkeit
vielleicht ganz schnell am rande novak
djokovic muss nicht in haft muss auch
nicht wieder in das hotel zurück wo er
am anfang gewohnt hat sondern kann in
seiner unterkunft bleiben es gibt morgen
ein gespräch oder eine vorladung mit den
mit den grenzbehörden und dann wird
geklärt wie es weitergeht was wir bisher
noch nicht ganz hundertprozentig genau
wissen
ist inwieweit und wann die rechtsanwälte
von novak djokovic einspruch einlegen
denn das ist grundvoraussetzung dass
hier weiter verhandelt wird
das heißt damit ist die frage auch von
christian rath schon beantwortet die
über youtube ihre meinung sagt diese
entscheidung ist richtig und sie fragt
muss djokovic jetzt wieder ins
quarantäne hotel das ist also derzeit
nicht der fall was hat djokovic in den
letzten stunden gemacht welche infos
gibt es da aus seinem umfeld
er hat eigentlich heute nachmittag
trainieren wollen um halb zwei uhr
australischer zeit viele hatten sich
darauf eingerichtet wir auch und dann
man höre und staune war schon um 9 uhr
30 in der rod laver arena auf dem
hauptplatz und hat dort trainiert wir
wissen jetzt warum weil nämlich sein
anwaltsteam ihn das geraten hat
möglichst den nachmittag sich frei zu
halten um sich zu besprechen das hat er
dann wohl anscheinend mit seinem
anwalts-team auch getan und hat morgens
ab halb zehn trainiert ganz normal zwei
stunden und ist dann nach dem er
geduscht hat dann hat er das stadion
verlassen und ist dann in die kanzlei
gefahren das heißt er muss also schon
gewusst haben wohin der in welche
richtung diese entscheidungen fallen
wird
ich denke schon denn wir erinnern uns
gestern wir hatten gestern ja auch
gesprochen da hat er das training schon
nach 20 minuten abgebrochen da hat er
von seinem physiotherapeuten sein
telefon gereicht bekommen dort hat er
eine sms empfangen inhalt unbekannt aber
wenn er das training abbricht dann muss
etwas ganz wichtiges gewesen sein denn
novak djokovic ist bekannt dafür dass er
sehr präzise sein pensum runter spult
auf dem tennisplatz er wollte sich
vorbereiten für die austrian open air
ist der titelverteidiger will hier
unbedingt seinen 21 titel gewinnen und
damit alleiniger rekordhalter von grand
slam turnieren werden jeweils 20 haben
auch seine mitstreiter und rivalen
rafael nadal und roger federer
und das scheint nun in weite ferne
gerückt denn die vorbereitung zum einen
ist alles andere als gut gewesen in den
letzten stunden und in den letzten tagen
und wer weiß ob er überhaupt wird
antreten können
nun ist die frage was die anderen sagen
gestern hatten wir tennisprofi michael
stich hier in der sendung wer hat gesagt
es ist nicht okay dass er nicht geimpft
ist es gibt ungereimtheiten
was diese einreise angeht aber jetzt ist
er da meine güte er hat trainiert jetzt
lasst ihn halt auch spielen was ist denn
die reaktionen der anderen spieler vor
ort
na ja es hat sich gestern zum ersten mal
der grieche stephanus city pass geäußert
hat gesagt also es geht uns allen
irgendwie ein bisschen jetzt gegen den
strich dass sie immer nur noch um eine
person dreht hier um novak djokovic
warum der sich nicht impfen lassen ist
mir ein absolutes rätsel wir alle haben
das gemacht warum er nicht dass stört
hier alle und hat sich da so ein
bisschen mit aus dem fenster gelehnt die
meisten haben gesagt na ja das ist seine
eigene sache das muss jeder selbst
wissen und wollten eigentlich nichts
dazu sagen heute hat sich dann auch
angie kerber dazu eingelassen in
gespräch unter anderem mit uns und hat
gesagt naja regeln sind regeln die
sollte man einhalten sie hätte das auch
getan sie hat sich sogar mit corona noch
vor weihnachten infiziert am 11 dezember
muss dann eine 14-tägige quarantäne im
letzten jahr wir erinnern uns ist sie im
flugzeug in einem jahr mit passagieren
zusammen gekommen die sich auch mit
corona angesteckt hatten dann musste sie
auch 14 tage in einem hotel quarantäne
also alles andere als super optimale
vorbereitungen und sie sagt auch dieses
jahr sie ist nicht 100 prozent matchfit
sie konnte das turnier in sydney zum
beispiel nicht spielen und sie meinte er
sollte sich besser impfen lassen denn
das ist der beste schutz den man sich
selbst angedeihen lassen kann sind wir
haben den o-ton vorliegen von angelique
kerber haben wir mal noch mal gemeinsam
rein natürlich verfolgt man das auch
hier
die letzten tage hat es glaube ich die
ganze welt mitverfolgt und ich hoffe
dass es bald auch mal wieder positive
nachrichten gibt aber ich verstehe
natürlich auch die australier die waren
über 200 tage die letzten jahre hier in
in quarantäne
aber am ende des tages ist es nicht
meine entscheidung ich bin selber
gespannt
regeln sind regeln egal für wen ob es
für die nummer eins ist oder für eine
qualifikantin
tja so weit als orange league kerber was
wirst du denn aus den anderen teams denn
es gibt ja noch mehr als die trainer als
die spieler es gibt ja auch die trainer
die ganzen teams um die spieler herum
was hört man da
ja ja die haben sich bis jetzt
zurückgehalten weil ja keiner so genau
wusste warum und weshalb es hat eine
ausnahmeregelung gegeben alle allerdings
sind einer meinung man hätte diese
ausnahmeregelung gar nicht aussprechen
sollen dann hätte man hier diesen stress
nicht und hätte sich jetzt schon längst
aufs tennis konzentrieren können denn
wer die auslosung normal vonstatten
gegangen auch das ist jetzt ja alles ein
bisschen durcheinander wenn djokovic
rausziehen muss dann wird der an fünf
gesetzte russe ruf an dessen stelle nach
vorne gerückt werden alles ein bisschen
kompliziert will ich auch gar nicht groß
hier weiter darauf eingehen nachteil ein
bisschen für alexander sascha das wäre
der jetzt eine relativ schwere auslosung
hatte in dem djokovic drin blieb im
wettbewerb der muss jetzt in der dritten
runde zum beispiel gegen den
südafrikaner laut harris spielen wenn er
denn überhaupt so weit kommt natürlich
vorausgesetzt in der vierten runde hat
er es dann mit dem kanal schapowalow
womöglich zu tun den marker auch nicht
so besonders ging ja auch schon verloren
und dann im viertelfinale showdown mit
rafael nadal hier an sechs gesetzt und
dadurch bei der
alexander zverev an drei gesetzes
treffen die beiden im viertelfinale
aufeinander oder im halbfinale würde
dann ja wenn er noch drin ist djokovic
warten oder womöglich der italiener
matteo bettini es werden kommen wir noch
mal zu zu den australien der
australische regierungschef scott
morrison hat sich auch inzwischen
geäußert hat die entscheidung seines
einwanderungsminister kommentiert mit
den worten diese pandemie war für jeden
australier unklar wie schwierig aber wir
haben zusammengehalten und leben und
existenzen gerettet die australier haben
während dieser pandemie viele opfer
gebracht und sie erwarten zu recht dass
das ergebnis dieser opfer auch geschützt
wird was hörst du denn von australischer
seite an reaktionen
ja die ist ganz eindeutig die meisten
also über 80 prozent so war hier eine
umfrage sind dafür dass djokovic nicht
antreten darf das er ausgewiesen werden
muss er ist ungeimpft dass es das
entscheidende kriterium
nur wer doppelt geimpft ist dafür soll
hier möglicherweise nur antreten wie du
schon sagtest die
australier spricht gerade die hier im
bundesstaat victoria waren 260 genauer
gesagt zwei einer 62 tage im lockdown
durften ihre wohnung oder ihr haus
maximal nur fünf kilometer verlassen und
das hat die hier ziemlich aufgebracht
und das hat ja auch ziemlich gestresst
und ja fast eine gewisse depressive
stimmung
verursacht jetzt geht es ihnen besser
wobei allerdings auch die zahlen hier
hochschnellen wir hatten schon über
40.000 neue infektionen an einem tag
alles natürlich mit vorbehalt heute
waren es knapp 35.000 und man hat auch
die zuschauerzahl oder beziehungsweise
die die möglichkeit der zuschauer
begrenzt hier zum tennis zu kommen
maximaler auslastung 50 prozent es wird
sicherlich einige geben die ihre karten
dann wieder zurückgeben müssen ganz kurz
hier an meinungsbild aus dem chat sind
viele die sagen wie zum beispiel düssel
gram über youtube australien macht alles
richtig mehr okan 58 schreibt auch über
youtube meiner meinung nach ist es für
alle beteiligten die beste lösung aber
es gibt auch viele unterstützer von
novak djokovic
die die da auf seiner seite sind also
soweit ein kurzer blick in den chat und
dann durch die letzte frage es sind ja
auch viele serbische fans vor ort gibt
es auf dieser richtung schon erste
reaktion
ja das werden wir sicherlich erleben
will wir erinnern uns am montag als es
eine falschmeldung gehabt in dem es hieß
man würde novak djokovic direkt zum zum
flughafen eskortieren sind die serben
alle allesamt zur kanzlei gekommen und
haben da protestieren wollen da gab es
auch stimmung mit der polizei da gab es
stress da gab es einsatz von
pfefferspray es leben hier deutlich über
20.000 serben in melbourne und die sind
sehr emotional aufgeladen ich habe mit
einem kollegen gesprochen vom serbischen
fernsehen von rts sascha jankovic der
sagte mir dass die serben in serbien in
belgrad komplett aus dem häuschen
negativ sind und sich aufregen und das
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen können
dass ihr liebling ihr novak djokovic
hier so viel ungemach bereitet wird es
wenn alle gehören vielen dank nach
melbourne wir sind gespannt wie die
geschichte weitergeht und gehen direkt
mit dem was du gesagt hast weiter nach
serbien in die heimat von novak djokovic
und fragen genau dort nach wie denn dort
die die lage ist wolf christian ullrich
ist in serbien gerade auf dem weg nach
belgrad war bis vor kurzem noch ins novi
sad der serbischen heimat von novak
djokovic wie ist dort die stimmung
guten morgen aus inzwischen trat die
stimmung ist ein bisschen verschlafen
sie müssen ja wissen gestern abend war
hier nach dem werbemotto docs und
calendar das silvesterfest da gab es
noch ein feuerwerk heute morgen ist ein
ganz normaler arbeitstag und natürlich
sind diese nachrichten aus melbourne
auch hier in serbien angekommen und
werden bei vielen auf großes
unverständnis stoßen das war ja beim
letzten mal auch schon so ich nehme
allerdings nicht an dass die redaktion
die reaktionen jetzt heute über quellen
werden einfach war ja der juristisch das
ganze noch im fluss ist sollte
allerdings novak djokovic wirklich in
einen flieger steigen und zurück nach
serbien kommen dann wird werden das
sicherlich viele sehr sehr enttäuscht
und ärgerlich sein denn man muss wissen
novak djokovic ist ja ein echter
nationalheld sie nennen ihn hole sie
lieben ihnen es ist jemand der einen
ganz großen weltweiten erfolg feiern
konnte der sich ganz nach oben
gearbeitet hat der weltweit beachtung
findet und darauf sind diese haben
wahnsinnig stolz diese ganze geschichte
in melbourne sehen die leute sehen
manche leute deshalb auch sehr emotional
sagen dass es unmöglich wie man ihn dort
behandelt andere haben wir gesprochen
die da ein bisschen ruhiger sind und
sagen na gut es ist ebenso man muss sich
auch an die regeln halten jeder der mal
in australien oder im ausland war in
anderen ländern war weiß man muss ganz
genau sein wenn es darum geht die
immigration boxes richtig an zu
kreuzen wenn er das nicht gemacht hat
dann muss eben mit den konsequenzen
leben als ein gespaltenes meinungsbild
die nachricht ist in den zeitungen heute
morgen online natürlich schon angekommen
aber hat sich jetzt hier auf der straße
und in der großen öffentlichkeit noch
nicht zu wie soll ich sagen empörung
ausbrüchen geführt nun gibt es ja auch
die frage nach konsequenzen
alexander hofstetter fragt zum beispiel
über youtube spanien könnte auch
ermitteln und fraglich ist ob er in
serbien belangt wird bei dem großen hype
um ihn und auch da hat sich ja die
serbische premier ministerin schon
geäußert und hat auch gesagt regeln sind
regeln auch hier bei uns in serbien wie
wie wie könnte das weitergehen in seiner
heimat
also
als diese ganze geschichte passiert ist
mit djokovic haben sich sofort der
präsident die premierministerin die
ganze politische klasse hinter novak
djokovic gestellt warum im sommer sind
parlamentswahlen und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass eine partei die vor
allen dingen durch populismus hier
erfolgreich ist irgendetwas tut um den
nationalhelden jetzt hier zu belangen in
irgendeiner weise also dass da fehlt mir
so ein bisschen die vorstellungskraft
das zweite ist ich kann ihn nur aus
meiner persönlichen erfahrung der
letzten zwei drei tage hier in serbien
sagen die omikron zahlen schießen hier
nach oben wir haben instanz ich müsste
jetzt noch mal gucken aber ich glaube es
geht auf die 1000 zu wenn sie unterwegs
sind da trägt keiner vernünftig maske
die hängt immer hier unten drunter dann
wird im restaurant nach einem impfpass
gefragt aber das gerät generelle gefühl
hier gibt es strenge regeln an die man
sich hält um etwas gegen korona zu tun
so wie sie das aus deutschland kennen
sowie das völlig aus österreich kennen
die zuschauer das ist hier deutlich
weniger und deshalb ist glaube ich auch
die empörung oder das unverständnis
darüber da das ist ein land gibt mit
australien dass diese regeln ganz ganz
anders und viel strenger gemacht hat ja
es ist einfach eine andere denkweise und
ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen dass
plötzlich die die serbische regierung an
novak djokovic eine regel exempel
statuieren möchte also das wird man
jetzt sagen aber da
ich bin immer noch zurückhaltend welche
rolle spielt denn die familie djokovic
es gab eine pressekonferenz in den
letzten tagen immer wieder äußerungen
auch vom vater auch die mutter hat sich
geäußert ist damit zu rechnen dass die
sich auch noch einmal äußern werden und
wenn ja in welcher richtung
ich glaube ganz sicher dass sie sich
äußern werden wir müssen verstehen hier
in diesem gebiet ist die familie alles
ist ganz ganz wichtig und wenn der sohn
in der ferne ist und probleme hat dann
halten alle ganz fest zusammen und
natürlich werden sich sicherlich heute
oder in den kommenden tagen die familien
noch mal äußern es waren zunächst der
äußerung die sehr empört waren sehr
aggressiv waren und dann bei der letzten
konferenz konferenz nach dem
gerichtsurteil war war der tote schon
wesentlich sanfter die werden
enttäuschung hören ganz klar wir werden
unverständnis hören dazu müssen sie
allerdings auch verstehen dass hier in
serbien die berichterstattung über
die die fehler die passiert sind über
die ungereimtheiten die es gegeben hat
auch ja mit diesem pcr test und den 26
so groß gar nicht gefahren worden sind
dh die leute nehmen möglicherweise gar
nicht dass so war wie sie das in
deutschland wahrnehmen und hören dass
also in den zeitungen jeder kleine
schritt aufgeführt ist was alles falsch
gelaufen ist sondern die leute wissen
einfach ein bisschen weniger und umso
größer ist denn das unverständnis
darüber was in diesem fernen land mit
ihrem großen star passiert und die
familie wird auf jeden fall zu novak
djokovic halten es wird sicherlich kann
ich mir vorstellen auch noch mal
kleinere veranstaltungen geben ich
glaube der punkt wird immer interessant
wenn djokovic wirklich nach der
juristischen
auseinandersetzung dann nach hause
fahren sollen müsste dann wird es hier
noch mal aufregung geben dann wird der
vater sicherlich nochmal mit dem megafon
auf die straße treten und dann werden
sicherlich seine anhänger auch nochmal
ihren unmut zum ausdruck bringen wolf
christian ulrich vielen dank für diese
einschätzungen nach belgrad vielen dank
dafür
und weil dieser krimi jetzt schon so
lange währt und man gar nicht mehr
nachvollziehen kann welche umdrehungen
denn alle noch passiert sind fast saar
alaska das nochmal für uns zusammen
die causa novak djokovic für die
australian open reiste der tennisprofi
nach australien allerdings ohne die
vorgeschriebene corona impfung deshalb
verweigerten ihm die behörden die
einreise djokovic landete im abschiebe
hotel bis ein richter die entscheidung
kippt für fans und familie ein wichtiger
erfolg der
richter war fantastisch er hat die
fakten berücksichtigt die unser
anwaltsteam präsentiert hatte
allerdings sind da diese ungereimtheiten
djokovic ein reisedokument da gab er an
nicht über ein drittland nach australien
eingereist zu sein fotos zeigen er flog
von serbien nach spanien von dort nach
australien hinzu kommen widersprüche bei
seiner corona infektion und auch die
tests zertifikate des tennisprofis
werfen fragen auf recherchen des spiegel
und der expertengruppe zur forschung
legen nahe dass daten nachträglich
geändert wurden djokovic trainierte
währenddessen weiter und hoffte wohl
dass er im land bleiben darf warum ihn
jetzt ein visum entziehen nachdem man
ihnen hat auch die anlage gehen lassen
auch da wie gesagt gibt australien der
turnier-veranstalter extrem schlechtes
bilder bdp die etf also alle beteiligten
haben halt angst eine entscheidung zu
treffen für die entscheidung ließ sich
der australische einwanderungsminister
in der tatzeit zeit in der sich auch das
herausstellte novak djokovic anfang
januar beim training in marbella spanien
eingereist bereits vor silvester wasser
aber wohl gar nicht durfte es deute
alles auf eine illegale einreise hin
ohne impfnachweis und sondergenehmigung
die er eigentlich gebraucht hätte die
regierung in madrid habe die polizei mit
der einleitung einer untersuchung
beauftragt berichten spanische medien
neben dem ärger mit australien droht
also auch streit mit den spanischen
behörden
harry sally aus unserer sportredaktion
wieder bei uns im studio guten morgen
aris wenn es stimmt was ich heute morgen
gelesen habt dann gibt's das ganze bald
auf netflix denn ich auch gelesen es
gibt tatsächlich ein team was djokovic
begleitet was eigentlich ein film über
ihn machen sollte und jetzt dieses ganze
szenario direkt mitverfolgt hat wäre das
was was du dir angucken würdest oder
wird zu sagen es ist echt ein
trauerspiel und langsam ist es thomas
also um es nacheinander zu beantworten
ich würde es mir nicht anschauen und ja
es ist ein trauerspiel das ist eine
farce ist leidig ich will dass der
tennis gespielt wird und dass sie sich
nicht weiter um herrn djokovic bemühen
kümmern machen
hock hat gesprochen und jetzt erstmal
ganz schön wenn das zu ende ginge was
bedeutet das für das turnier reden wir
erst mal über das turnier also es gibt
ein tableau leute wissen nicht bleibt es
bei der auslosung wird der spielen wird
er spielen muss er dann nachdem er zwei
spiele gespielt hat doch zurück also
keiner weiß irgendwas in maximaler
unsicherheit in so ein turnier zu gehen
wie ist das
sagen wir mal bei den gegnern bei den
möglichen gegnern an für die ist das
richtig blöd also wenn ich mir die autos
und angucke als tennisspieler dann
bereite ich mich ja gedanklich schon auf
das vor was in der ersten zweiten
dritten runde was möglicherweise dann
wenn es wichtig wird viertelfinale
halbfinale auf mich zukommt wenn ich
aber nicht weiß ob er djokovic spielt
der nummer eins gesetzt ist im
sogenannten oberen tableau man muss sich
das vorstellen sind tannenbaum der quer
zur seite legt rechts an der spitze ist
das finale und links nach von oben nach
unten die 128 spieler sind glaube ich
wenn man eben nicht weiß was auf einen
zukommt dann macht das maximal unsicher
ja und es
kann auch sein dass manche davon
profitieren also zb andere hrubesch der
der russe der von position fünf gesetzt
am 5 dann auf einmal an eins gesetzt
würde wenn djokovic ausgedacht eine
etwas leichtere auslosung bis zum
viertelfinale halbfinale also es gibt da
gewinner und verlierer wenn man es mal
sehr sehr plakativ sagen möchte aber
insgesamt ist die situation eine ganz
schlechte und bei djokovic 6 eigentlich
eher so dass dem ist das egal der will
das spielen und bei dem ist es so er ist
halt die nummer eins der welt er hat
eine dna gehört verlieren nicht
unbedingt dazu das sieht man jetzt auch
in dem fall ob er nach hause reisen soll
er dann nicht er will das durchstehen
bis zuletzt verlieren gehört bei ihm
nicht zum gedankengutes keine option
wenn er spielen soll spielt da und wenn
er spielen will spielt auch gut und dann
will auch gewinnen wir auch gewinnen auf
jeden fall es gibt zwei fragen im chat
an dich einmal von jutta heimann über
facebook gefragt sind überhaupt alle
teilnehmer geimpft oder es djokovic der
einzige ungeimpfte tennisspieler und pay
fragt auch über youtube selbe frage gibt
es andere tennisspieler die nicht
geimpft sind und am turnier teilnehmen
das ist eine sehr gute frage die ich
leider nicht vollständig beantworten
kann einfach deswegen weil tennis
australia mit diesen sondergenehmigungen
diese tatsächlich auch erteilt haben
leider nicht transparent umgehen wir
wissen nicht wer das ungeimpft wer hat
eine sondergenehmigung bekommen
dass das wissen wir alles nicht das ist
ein puzzle teil dieses ganzen
schauspiels das ein ratlos zurücklässt
wenn damit transparent umgegangen wäre
würden sich manche fragen vielleicht von
auch viel einfacher beantworten lassen
das ist nicht der fall also wir wissen
es nicht dass man kann aber davon
ausgehen ich hätte dich hat das gestern
schon gesagt dass sportler wenn das ja
bei user kimmig vom fc bayern münchen
erlebt sich sehr wohl überlegen ob sie
sich impfen lassen oder nicht dass eine
freie entscheidung sicherlich ob es eine
sinnvolle ist das wage ich mal zu
bezweifeln aber
die denken drei mal drüber nach ob sie
sich impfen lassen ob das den körper in
irgendeiner weise im leistungssport
beeinflusst aber gerade stichwort
transparenz das ist eine von vielen
fragen die sich gerade die australischen
tennis verbände gefallen lassen müssen
uns natürlich auch eine frage für
zukünftige turniere denn das thema
ungeimpfte sportler das wird ja in
zukunft bei allen möglichen anderen
turnieren auch noch geben es gab den
fall von ich weiß ich hab ich's richtig
aussprechen renata voracova aus
tschechien worte die auch nicht geimpft
war und wie djokovic einreisen wollte
dann aber vom quarantäne hotel zurück
geflogen ist das weniger drastischer
ich-erzähler die die hat schon ein four
turnier gespielt die war schon auf dem
tennisplatz hat matches gespielt und
dann hat man diese einreisegenehmigung
rückgängig gemacht und dann wurde es
ihnen dieses abschiebe hotel gesteckt
und
hat dann diese ganze modalitäten
mitmachen müssen dass sie sagte sein
albtraum artig gewesen das will sie auch
tennis australia bitten die kosten die
entstanden sind also zusätzliche
flugkosten usw entgangene preisgelder
ist eine doppelspielerin hier durchaus
hätte erste runde überstehen können die
entgangen sein könnten will sie ersetzt
haben also auch das ist völlig planlos
für mich aus meiner sicht und auch
vielleicht auch für viele tennisfans die
kann jemand einreisen wie kann jemand
auf dem platz stehen wie kann jemand
spiel und dann überlegt man sich doch
nicht das ist nicht transparent und das
ist auch nicht gut und doppelt nicht
nachvollziehbar wenn sie aus tschechien
jetzt die elvis turnier verfolgt am
fernseher während djokovic am ende
vielleicht dann doch spielen kann also
das ist schon ein bisschen verrückt das
ist wirklich bezogen noch ein paar
meinungen hier aus dem chat marcel
springer schreibt über facebook niemand
steht über dem gesetz auch ein
tennisspieler nicht es gibt in
australien geltendes recht sie waren
lange im lock down und dann kommt er und
will tennis spielen wenn er jetzt am
ende spielen sollte ich habe gelernt
dass das turnier in melbourne auch immer
happy slam genannt wurde weil es das
turnier ist was mit viel emotionen auch
von den fans einhergeht das wetter ist
schön mitunter sehr heiß spielerische
herausforderung aber es ist es ist
eigentlich ein fröhliches turnier liegt
da jetzt ein schatten drüber liegt es
ich war selbst schon dort bei diesem
turnier hat das erleben können die
stimmung ist eine ganz andere als
beispielsweise bei den french open oder
in london bilden oder bei den us open
ist es typisch ossi lag also australiens
lebensstil setzt sich der komplett drauf
und deswegen sind die spieler und
spielerinnen sehr gerne in australien
spielen dieses erste grand slam turnier
des jahres mit sehr viel wonne
tennis ist eine sehr populäre sportart
sehr im bewusstsein vieler jetzt rückt
der sport in den hintergrund das thema
impfen in den vordergrund die politik
schaltet sich ein was bedeutet dieses
dieser fall djokovic für den tennissport
machen wir's mal so ich glaube das wird
für die spieler möglicherweise ein
argument sein für welche die sich noch
nicht impfen lassen wollten sich impfen
zu lassen
ich finde dass die pandemie nicht halt
machen kann vor oder die pandemischen
regeln so um mich halt machen können vor
dem individualismus der der sportler das
dass das geht nicht und ich finde das
tut tennisspielern ganz gut ich
versuch's mal einzugrenzen das tut den
tennisspielern ganz gut die fürstlich
verdienen sagen wir die ersten 20 30 der
welt sowohl bei den frauen als auch bei
den männern um mal ein bisschen wieder
auf die erde und auf die füße zu kommen
um auch mal zu erkennen dass der planet
tennis nichts mit dem planet erde zu tun
hat
jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen drastisch
aber ich sehe das genauso und mir geht
das langsam auf den nerv muss jetzt
aufpassen dass es nicht zu emotional
werde
ich versuchen ein anderes beispiel zu
sagen wir haben glaube ich 6,9 millionen
einwohner in serbien in etwa so viel wie
in der schweiz da gab es mal eine nummer
eins der welt der ist roger federer
beliebt über alle maßen über alle
grenzen wäre dem so was passiert ich
behaupte zu 100 prozent nein
das mag mit ein paar gehirnwindungen
mehr zu tun haben aber wer weiß was sich
gehört und bei nowak vermisse ich das
dann kommen wir zum schluss zu einer
wieder sportlichen frage martin
sassenberg fragt über youtube meine
frage was tippt der kollege wer gewinnt
das turnier aber
interessant ja auch da wieder sollte ich
heute abend vielleicht lotto spielen
wenn ich den richtigen sieger titel also
es gibt
sagen wir mal so ich habe vier im auge
ghani medwedew nummer 2 der welt das
wären 3 der welt und
man darf rafael nadal nicht vergessen
nadal hat 20 grand slam siege renner da
gewinnt hat der 21 dann hat er das
alleinstellungsmerkmal was djokovic zu
gerne hätte und
ich glaube dass das unter denen dass das
rennen ausgemacht wird djokovic ist wenn
er spielt trotzdem nicht der ist ein
favorit aber nicht der favorit er ist
einer von 45 die das turnier gewinnen
können sagt aris donzelli wir sind
gespannt in sportlicher hinsicht und
auch was das ganze drumherum angeht und
können an dieser stelle zwar den deckel
auf diesen stream machen aber nicht auf
den fall djokovic denn der geht in die
nächste runde vielen dank fürs zuschauen
und mitmachen bis zum nächsten mal
schießt